welcome to this presentation on
logarithm properties now this is going
to be a very hands-on presentation if
you don't believe that one of these
properties are true and you want them
proved
i i've made three or four videos that
actually prove these properties but what
i'm going to do is i'm going to show you
the properties and then show you how
they can be used it's going to be a
little more hands-on so let's just do a
little bit of a of a review of just what
a what a logarithm is
so if i say that
a
oh that's that's not the right
let's see i want to change
there you go let's say i say that a
let me let me start over
a
to the b
is equal to c
so if we
a to the b power is equal to c so
another way to write this exact same
relationship but instead of writing an
exponent is to write it as a logarithm
so we could say that the logarithm
the logarithm
base a
of c
is equal to b
so
these are essentially saying the same
thing they just have different kind of
results in one you know a and b and
you're kind of getting c that's what
exponentiation does for you and the
second one you know a and you know that
when you raise it to some power you get
c and then you figure out what b is so
they're the exact same relationship just
stated in a different way
now i will introduce you to some
interesting logarithm properties and
they actually just fall out of out of
this relationship out of our out of this
relationship and the regular exponent
rules
so the first is
that the logarithm
let me do a more cheerful
color
the logarithm
let's say of any base so let's just call
the base let's say b for base
logarithm base b
of a
plus
logarithm
base b
of c and this only works if we have the
same basis so that's that's important to
remember
that equals
the logarithm
of base b
of
a
times
c
now what does this mean and how can we
use it or let's just even try it out
with with some uh well i don't know
examples so this is saying that
i'll switch to another color let's make
move my mob i don't i never know how to
say that proper let's make that my my my
example color so let's say
logarithm
of base 2
of i don't know
of 8
plus
logarithm
base 2
of
i don't know
let's say 32
so
in theory
this should equal if we believe this
property this should equal
logarithm
base two
of what well we say
eight times thirty two so eight times
thirty two is two hundred forty
plus sixteen two fifty six
two hundred and fifty six
let's see if that's true just trying out
this number and this really isn't a
proof but it'll give you a little bit of
an intuition i think for what's going on
around here so log so this is we just
use our property this little property
that i presented to you and let's see if
it's if it works out so log base 2 of 8.
2 to what power is equal to 8.
well 2 to the third power is equal to 8
right
2 to the third power is equal to 8. so
this term right here that equals 3 right
log base 2 of 8 is equal to 3.
2 to what power is equal to 32
let's see 2 to the 4th power is 16 2 to
the fifth power is 32.
so this is right here is
2 to the this is 5 right
and 2 to the what power is equal to 256.
well
let's see well if you're a computer
science major you'll know that
immediately that a byte can have 256
values in it so it's 2 to the 8th power
but if you don't know that you could
multiply it out yourself but this is
eight and i'm not doing it just because
i knew that three plus five is equal to
eight i'm doing this independently
so this is equal to eight but it does
turn out that three plus five
is equal to eight
this may seem like magic to you or it
may seem obvious and for those of you
who it might seem a little obvious
you're probably thinking well
two to the third
times
two to the fifth
is equal to
two to the three plus five right this is
just an exponent rule i what they call
this the additive exponent i don't know
i don't know the names of things and
that equals two to eight two to the
eighth
and that's exactly what we did here
right on this side we have two to the
third times two to the fifth essentially
and on this side you have them added to
each other and what makes logarithms
interesting is and why
it's a little confusing at first and you
can watch the proofs if you really want
a kind of a rigorous uh not even my
proof's not rigorous but if you want
kind of a better explanation of how this
works
but this should hopefully give you an
intuition for why this property holds
right because when you multiply two
numbers of the same base
right two exponent exponential
expressions of the same base you can add
their exponents
similarly when you have the log of two
numbers multiplied by each other
that's equivalent to
the log of each of the numbers added to
each other this is the same property
if you don't believe me watch watch the
uh the proof videos
so let's do a let me show you another
another
log property
that's pretty much the same one i almost
view them let's say so this is log
base b
of a
minus
log
base b
of c
is equal to
log
base b
of well i'm running out of space a
divided by c that says a divided by c
and we can once again try it out with
some with some numbers i use 2 a lot
just because 2 is an easy number to
to figure out the powers but let's use a
different number let's say log
log base 3
of uh
i don't know
log base 3 of well you know let's make
it interesting let's log base 3 of
1 9.
minus
log
base 3
of 81.
so this property
this property tells us that this is the
same thing as well i'm ending up with
the big number log
base 3
of
1 9
divided by 81 so that's the same thing
as 1 9 times 1 over 81. i'm i use two
large numbers for my
for my example but we'll we'll move
forward so let's see nine times eight is
720 right nine times
right nine times eight is seven twenty
so this is one over seven twenty nine
so this is log
base three over
one over seven twenty nine
so what what does three to what power is
equal to one ninth
well three squared is equal to 9 right
3 squared is equal to 9. so 3
so we know that you know if 3 squared is
equal to 9 then we know that 3 to the
negative 2 is equal to 1 9 right the
negative just inverts it so this is
equal to
negative 2
right
and then minus
3 to what power is equal to 81 i see 3
to the third power is 27 so 3 to the 4th
power
so we have minus two minus four
is equal to
well we could do it a couple of ways
minus two minus four is equal to minus
six
and now we just have to confirm that
three to the minus six power is equal to
one over seven twenty nine so my
question is 3 to the minus 6 power is
that equal to 7
1 over 729
well that's the same thing as saying 3
to the 6th power is equal to 729 because
that's all the negative exponent does
this inverts it
let's see we could multiply that out but
that should be the case because well we
could look here but let's see 3 to the
3 to the third power
this would be 3 to the third power times
3 to the third power is equal to 27
times 27
that looks pretty close you can you can
confirm it with a calculator if you
don't believe me
anyway that's all the time i have in
this video in the next video i'll
introduce you to the the last two
logarithm properties and if we have time
maybe i'll i'll do uh examples with the
with the leftover time i'll see you soon